it's a big night for bogey and we should
say a big night for bogey and baby and
Lulu Stefan massage okay Dani drop the
gun I know you're all extremely anxious
to hear who won the award for the best
actress of 1951 so without further ado
I'll give you a distinguished Academy
Award winner mr. Ronald Colman
I'm sorry to have given you such a brief
introduction on if you know how people
are getting terribly nervous and all yes
yes III know Danny thank you thank you I
think we oughtn't keep them suspended oh
no no they must they're on the edge of
their seats we better go I think yes
because I really think if anybody do
anything I mean a you've been in that
position before I'm sure on a I mean
being nervous about who's felony or I I
don't think we really ought to waste my
time I think you ought to get on with
hmm I think you ought to get on oh yes
yes I I think yeah do you mind no no no
no it isn't don't trust those nominated
for the Best Performance by an actress
are Katharine Hepburn and the African
Queen
verizon enterprises incorporated United
Artists Vivian Leigh in a streetcar
named desire Charles K Feldman group
productions one of others Eleanor Parker
in detective story paramount Shelley
Winters in a Place in the Sun
paramount and Jane Wyman in the blue
veil Walt crasner productions
incorporated RKO radio and the envelope
please
the winner is Vivien Leigh and as
not here to accept the award miss Greer
Garson one at 1942 for her portrayal of
mrs. Miniver is here to accept it for
her the phenomena and I'm thrilled to
accept this for you Vivien I hope you're
listening in New York we're all there
inside of the bottle god bless you and
congratulations I know she would want to
thank you she were here Hester this is
the second award originally she received
in Austria amazement
for me Scarlett O'Hara in Gone with the
Wind